the specialist assault team
or sat is the japanese paramilitary
counter-terrorism unit
under the national police agency
cooperating with the anti-firearms
encounter nbc terrorism squads the sat
is mandated for counter-terrorism
missions
and incidents involving firearms or
criminals which require an armed
response
beyond the capabilities of local law
enforcement
the origin of the special assault team
can be traced back to september 28
1977 when tokyo and osaka began to train
special armed police units
as a response to criminal incidents
involving firearms
the existing special firearms squad with
basic sniper and entry teams
but were only part-time but in 1977
the dhaka incident took headlines around
the world
japan airlines flight 472 was hijacked
by the communist militant and terrorist
group
known as the japanese red army it was
realised that japan was ill-equipped to
deal with such an act of terrorism
following the event the national police
agency decided to set up secret
full-time anti-terrorism special units
at the tokyo metropolitan and osaka
police department
the tokyo unit was nicknamed sap or
special armed police
this name was made official by 1982
information on the unit was highly
confidential and its existence was never
officially acknowledged until 1996
where it was announced that these
tactical units had been organized
after a year of training with the gsg-9
gign
and the british sas the unit name was
changed to special assault teams
sat is involved in hostage rescue
anti-hijacking
supporting civil police in combat
providing superior assault firepower
engaging of strongly armed criminal
groups and serving high risk at risk
warrants
members are recruited from riot police
units when the unit was first set up the
members were selected from rangers
rescue specialists snipers and martial
artists
it is said that they recruit officers
under the age of 30 years old
in order to maintain peak physical
strength their period of service is
approximately 5 years
upon recruitment to the sat the
officer's name is made classified from
the roster of active police officers
this is to protect them from being
attacked by criminals extremists
and terrorist groups after the
reactivation of team rainbow in 2015
two sat operators were recruited to
bring their skills and expertise
to assist in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale
these operators were named hibana and
[Music]
echo
[Music]
yumiko iwagawa codenamed hibana
is an attacking operator in team rainbow
born and raised in nagoya the fourth
largest city in japan
while her mother stayed at home raising
her and her sister her father worked as
a butcher
being a proud and diligent housewife
hibana's mother wouldn't allow him
inside the house until he'd been hosed
down in the garden
by her children drenched in frigid water
and dancing barefoot
is a fond memory hibana often recounts
with her friends
from an early age she was encouraged by
appearance to engage in
kaiodo the japanese martial art of
archery
or the way of the bow within her this is
instilled
a groundness and innocence serenity as
in modern day practice
it encompasses the spiritual discipline
of meditation
when practicing the art of hyudo the
goal is not to hit the target
but to open one's heart and spirit to
the technique
as when all is in balance the arrow will
reach the destination
along with kyudo she became an adept and
skilled martial artist
and at the age of 18 joined the national
police academy
there she further developed her tactical
versatility and because of her strong
vivacious and witty style of leadership
along with the unique explosive devices
she earned the nickname
hibana which means spark
she was later recruited by the aichi
police department special assault team
where she flourished and quickly
ascended the ranks due to her charisma
and various techniques she acquired
further adaptability in a various
training
including proficiency and performing
assaults in tubular spaces such as buses
trains and airplanes
a unique and well-traveled individual
she speaks seven languages fluently
and her other specialization includes
being adept at counter gorilla
over warfare time with the sat she has
trained with a number of different units
including the fbi swat and gogn
her expertise in gaining entry to
high-risk areas and on-rush tactics
is legendary she is the sort of
individual who inspires others
even went from vastly different
backgrounds to herself
the ease at which other operators find
themselves in makes her an exceptional
asset
in a magnitude of situations yet she
remains gracious and kind
never letting the other's admiration of
her to get to her head
hibana has a solid working relationship
with thermite who is like a mentor to
her
and beside their professional
collaborations they are also
most notably very good friends
a secret or maybe not so secretive
relationship seems to exist between her
and pulse there are a number of
indications
that this relationship may be serious
including pulse's invitational charm
titled pulse's heart which features the
japanese name
yumiko inscribed on it which of course
is first name
also there is a photo of the two of them
on fortress and she appears to be
wearing his charm
as a necklace pulse has furthermore
become obsessed with working on being
more in the moment
slowing time and striving to be more
mindful of others
he is also valiantly attempting to learn
japanese in order to impress habana
which has meant he's been hanging around
operator echo a lot
much to ekko's annoyance
specialist dokkaebi and habana who often
spend a lot of time together in the lab
seem to have a rather tense relationship
while it's not crystal clear where this
tension comes from
it may have something to do with their
vastly different personalities
hibana may envy dokkaebi's easy
self-assurance
just as she did her younger sister her
younger sibling who always appeared to
have immense confidence
in everything that she would say and do
and she was constantly displaying
sureness
in her own abilities and likewise
dokkaebi exhibits the same confidence
she has always broken others
expectations of her she excels in
everything she has ever put in mind to
and although there is times she is
buttered headed with the superiors
she knows how to play the game and she
plays it well
whereas hibana has always had a sense of
grace calm sensibility
and is universally respected by her
peers
but deep down there lies an unsureness
about herself
[Music]
she has worked hard on her tranquility
focused on her inner quietness
and put forward a stoic persona to
others
so therefore it should come as no
surprise that at times hibana can become
notably impatient
with dokabi who is playful clever
serious and reckless
not that she appears to notice or even
care
while attending a special operations
conference in jordan
hibano met thurmite a pioneer in
brimstone bc3
exothermic experiments she collaborated
with them to develop the x
kairos a 40 millimeter grenade launcher
this weapon is capable of firing
explosive pellets that can be detonated
simultaneously from a distance
masaru inatsu codenamed ekko
is a defending operator in team rainbow
on the outer borders of tokyo lies the
city tsujinami
the hometown of ekko
although he is an only child and has
never had to compete for his parents
affections with siblings
he has never been close to them even
when he was a small boy
if there is one lesson in particular
that he has learned from his parents
it is that is a sign of weakness to
switch off and he has been conditioned
to believe that a restful mind
indicates a lack of intelligence
his parents have always been somewhat
aloof and he is often joked that a
calculator has more emotional range than
they do
as a result he learned from a very young
age to be self-sufficient
and became accustomed to working on his
own
over time this has made him very
resistant to working with others
as he lacked many of the skills and how
to effectively communicate
and it's of no surprise really as it's
all he's ever known
so he thought that he didn't need anyone
else and his role models only further
solidified these ideas
therefore it's easy to see why he could
absolutely lose himself
in the world of robotics people in their
emotions confuse him
whereas robotics is a deeply fascinating
subject in which he could put all of his
energy and time into without the need of
human to human communication
it requires time to learn such a
specialized skill dedication
and the understanding of the bigger
picture and how to achieve the desired
product
so for ekko robotics was the perfect fit
he could carry out his work in solitude
and didn't have to rely on the
companionship
or input of others
over time he learned how to construct
and program his own robotics and drones
and began competing in numerous
competitions in which often
he won at tokyo metropolitan university
he studied electrical and electronic
engineering which focused on the
development of new technologies
while addressing the issues of
sustainable development and the
importance of reducing environmental
impacts
not long after graduating he joined the
research and development laboratory at
the national agency security bureau
and there he began inventing specific
tech that would aid them in the field
he was trained in anti-terrorism and
intelligence gathering
and also began designing specific tech
that would better aid the bureau
joint training experience after the
nagoya hostage crisis
prompted ekko to transfer to the ikea
police department special unit
whereas a relentless focus enabled him
to find creative solutions and
alternative strategies
eventually he returned to tokyo where
his exceptional mind
and intel gathering techniques had
caught the attention of rainbow
he works alongside fellow operator
hibana for the sat
and over time he is learning to work in
a group with a number of operators
that is both friendly and is a mutually
beneficial dynamic for everyone
however he still gets frustrated easily
by others and struggles to communicate
his ideas or intentions
which at times can lead to high tension
and misunderstandings
nonetheless it does seem to have
developed mutual understanding with
specialist kevira
as they are both direct and outspoken
individuals who believe that those who
are offended by them
simply don't get the joke an example is
when he was discussing the advice given
to him by specialist alibi
he confessed that he thought albert's
suggestions were pretty smart for
someone without an engineering degree
other operators he's worked closely with
includes durkerby
who he has worked with on a number of
projects
while they're on friendly terms they can
become quite competitive
especially when trying to outdo each
other in the workshop
in 2005 he collaborated with the hong
kong special duties unit
where he met specialist yin where the
two became romantically involved
before breaking up a year later while it
said that their relationship didn't
progress further
it should come with no surprise as he
has few outside interests other than
robotics
and consequently only thinks about
improving his own operational efficiency
ying on the other hand is easygoing
blends well with others
takes enjoyment in working with the team
and has an effective way of making
people feel comfortable
and secure
echo's tactics have often been described
as tricky and unpredictable
he is always active and never seems to
shut off
this can make it hard to relate to
others as he doesn't recognize the
importance of downtime
and that everyone needs diversions
especially those in high stress jobs
known as disputing his intelligence or
his skill he is clearly an incredibly
valuable team member
while his biggest struggle may be
relating to others his desire
to explore the ai of his fellow
operators by pushing their buttons
is something that may be useful in
teaching him the social skills that he
so surely needs
for the future furthermore as much as he
may not realize it
and may even try to hide it he needs
these people
and he needs team rainbow there is
family
[Music]
in an attempt to overcome the
limitations of ranged weapons
ekko developed a drone called yukai
equipped with an acoustic hailing device
the drain releases disorientating sonic
bursts within a given perimeter
on top of this it transmits a video feed
back to echo allowing him to keep his
immediate location
secure
these are certainly slow burners these
videos but i've had quite a few of you
asking me to continue with the series
which is cool because i really enjoy
reading up on these guys
obviously based on the views there are
more popular groups out there
like the sas and spesners generally the
larger more well-known groups
but which individual operator stories
have you liked so far
let me know in the comments otherwise
thank you very much for watching and
i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
you